so when we talk about drought when we
talk about the scarcity of water we
really have to look at our
infrastructure and use that water more
efficiently we've got 60 billion dollars
to focus on that and the president has
said at least 40
of that 60 billion dollars must go to
communities that look like ours
it's this kind of leadership that is
beginning to change the landscape and i
would argue that washington dc doesn't
have all the answers
but now that we have the resources we
should partner with you all as community
advocates because you've had the
solutions for decades now i will have to
say i love lotting praise on my brother
here
if we are successful tomorrow and he has
this vote
epa will receive another 40 billion
dollars
3 billion
[Applause]
3 billion of those dollars will go to
environmental justice and equity this is
the first time in this country's history
that we have begun to acknowledge that
because of your race your income your
zip code that you have been unfairly
treated disproportionately impacted by
pollution
which has a cascading effect and impact
on how our children learn how they
breathe how they live
where they play uh we're talking about
pumping billions of dollars into our
communities to begin to revive and
uplift them in a way that they should
have been done the entire time so